we begin with breaking news a shake-up
in the white house communications team
CBS News has confirmed communications
director Mike dougie is out this move
comes as a roll of President Trump
senior advisor and son-in-law Jared
Kushner is also under scrutiny
the FBI is focused on Kushner for
allegedly trying to establish
back-channel communications with Russia
major Garrett is at the White House with
the latest on the story major good
morning good morning the Mike EE move
has been in the works for a good long
while and by itself in no way
constitutes a major shake-up of this
White House communications team but more
big moves are in the offing and could
happen very soon here yesterday Trump's
first campaign manager Corey Lewandowski
and his deputy campaign manager in the
homestretch of the campaign David bossy
were here they met with the president
and all white West Wing senior staff
both could be brought into this White
House or assigned by this White House to
create a war room to deal with the
ongoing Russia investigation stories in
his first Memorial Day speech as
commander-in-chief President Trump
called fallen US soldiers heroes we can
never repay them but we can always
remember free done oh the president
paused after laying a wreath at the Tomb
of the Unknown Soldier later he met
families and a mother memorializing her
son you take care you saw the solemnity
of the day contrast with continuing
drama inside the White House top advisor
and son-in-law Jared Kushner is now a
focus of the investigation into possible
collusion between the Trump campaign and
transition with Russian officials or
operatives CBS News has confirmed that
when Kushner met with Russian ambassador
Sergei kis lyac in December the two
discussed setting up a back-channel for
communications between the Trump
transition team and Russian officials
administration aides describe that as
standard procedure I don't like it I
just don't but Republican Senator John
McCain said what standard for the Trump
team isn't I don't think its standard
procedure prior to the inauguration of a
president
United States by someone who is not in
an appointed position the negative
publicity has made Kushner vulnerable
for the first time and made space for
chief strategist Steve Bannon to regain
some influence but Kushner's allies
argue that President Trump considers the
best part of his recently completed
foreign trip the three legs that Kushner
organized Saudi Arabia Israel and Rome
that work like the 110 billion dollar
arms deal with the Saudis Jared helped
negotiate is valued most by mr. Trump
the president told the New York Times
about Jared Kushner he has total
confidence in in him adding he is a very
good person
Alex major thanks